And so,
taking advantage,
Mr. President,
of the Los Pinos cultural complex,
it is carrying out a project for ethical control and real protection of cats.
Could this same project be replicated in the National Palace?
Any response to these comments?
Well,
here are the cats,
this one,
well taken care of,
They lack a home of their own.
Of these they have everything,
don't they?
Huh?
All of them.
In other words,
this
I'm going to show you someday,
eh?
This one,
How,
this dominate.
This one,
here.
This,
How is this,
your attention given when there are?
Yes,
they stand there,
yes,
in front of me and no one touches them.
In other words,
and there they are,
yes.
And they have special attention.
This one,
doctors come to see them.
In other words,
they are well taken care of.
Yes,
but anyway,
this one,
we have to continue with that.
And let's see,
about the message,
if you leave it to Jesus.